- Okay people.
The school board
is making us discuss
the dangers
of drugs with you.
Two cops are here
to talk about it.
Listen, don't listen,
I don't give a shit.
[inhales deeply]
Mmm.
- So you little kids
like drugs?
[cheering]
- Who doesn't?
- You think a little puff-puff,
snort-snort's cool, huh?
Sound like fun?
[cheering]
- Yeah, I'm high right now.
- Well, we'll see
how you feel about drugs
after this slide show.
- The fuck
is a slide show?
- [inhales deeply]
- This is Timothy.
Handsome, innocent, smart.
Only half Jew.
He was on his way
to Harvard Business School
on a full scholarship.
- Until he met JaMarcus.
JaMarcus introduced
Timothy to marijuana.
Now Timothy is
a fat, blimp loser
who can't see his feet
and smells like Funyons.
- Legend.
- This is Chang Chu Lu.
Honorable, disciplined,
and we're assuming,
excellent at math.
- Until he met JaMarcus.
- Damn, JaMarcus out here
slingin' like the boy Marlo.
- It only took
one snort of nose candy
before Chang
believed he could fly.
He couldn't.
- Oh, snap!
- Last and least,
meet Darryl.
Darryl was an honor student
and star of his football team,
who surprisingly had
no illegitimate children
or police record.
- Until he met...
all: JaMarcus!
- JaMarcus gave Darryl molly.
It's a popular party drug,
known to help kids
lose their inhibitions.
[cheering]
- Yeah, get it Darryl.
- Darryl caught AIDS.
- Ooh.
- Oh.
- Not the Magic Johnson kind,
the full-blown,
Matthew McConaughey
in "Dallas Buyers Club" kind.
- Nigga what?
- So kids,
if somebody
offers you drugs,
just say no.
- Man, don't nobody
have to offer us drugs.
We already got them shits.
- You don't got
them shits anymore.
We raided your lockers
this morning.
As of right now,
Chamberlain Heights
is drier than
your teacher's clam.
[class groaning]
- Is my insulin in there?